[Aplausos]
hola buenos días a todos en primer lugar
dar gracias a ted ex por invitarme
y además de hacer un tema tan importante
como es el diversos
habéis visto que han llamado gorri y no
han dicho un nombre es que yo tengo un
nombre pero soy gorri vale y gorri es
todo y todo todo lo que soy soy yo una
persona que tiene un diagnóstico grave y
duradero en salud mental qué quiere
decir eso que mi mente
según unas personas está enferma
qué ha pasado nosotros hemos generado un
movimiento a base de crear un
diferente de hablar en diferentes
espacios y crear una asociación en una
asociación en la que sólo estamos
personas con diagnóstico en salud mental
gestionando la y llevando la vale en la
que creemos que lo que llaman enfermedad
mental no existe
vale eso no quiere decir que no
necesitamos una medicación o que estemos
en contra de la medicación lo que
decimos es que la enfermedad mental no
existe vale cuál es la diferencia es
fácil
la enfermedad mental tiene un
diagnóstico exterior nadie te puede
poner delante de tu boca desde tu ojos
un diagnóstico en el que ponga tú eres
esquizofrénico si no se tratan unos
síntomas y según vas van dedicando te
van probando te dicen al final pues tú
tomas medicación para esquizofrénicos
entonces ya te dicen eres esquizofrénico
no y eso pues como comprenderéis es muy
raro que tenía que tomar miles de
pastillas nosotros consideramos que de
verdad la enfermedad mental es
sufrimiento
puro y duro sufrimiento vale y yo os voy
a poner un ejemplo que es muy sencillo y
vamos a entenderlo había en la misma
época dos físicos muy importantes uno
fue edison todos conocemos a edison
verdad
fue la persona que inventó la corriente
continua la bombilla al que se le dio y
otro fue otro físico eléctrico que se
llamaba tesla que no sé si le conocería
es la mayoría le conocería esos otros no
vale
edison fue un visionario
y tesla fue un esquizofrénico
cuál era la gran diferencia entre los
dos
es la sufría edición no pero los dos
veían tenían visiones los dos veían lo
que lo que iban a crear los dos podían
ver más allá de lo que si os fijáis
además la mayoría de los visionarios que
einstein
edison
pues steve jobs gandín
ellos eran visionarios y no se les
llamaba esquizofrénicos aunque tenían
visiones
pero tienen un rasgo en común hacían
infelices a todos los que tenían
alrededor
vale eran personas con un ego muy alto y
en cambio las otras personas como tesla
podría decir más van gogh
podemos todos todos sabemos de mucha
gente que con una esquizofrenia con una
enfermedad mental ha sido ha sido un
gran personaje histórico 'alejandro
magno' se dijo que tenía también
bipolarismo o sea que era bipolar por lo
tanto la enfermedad mental no es tanto
una enfermedad como un estado
vale bajo nuestro punto de vista y este
estado es el sufrimiento que no vemos
que padecen una serie de personas en un
grado superlativo en el que no pueden
aguantar más vale hay diferentes clases
de sufrimientos en mi caso en el mío son
la mayoría de las veces es una soledad y
una pena que llega a doler físicamente
que hace daño físicamente vale no es que
estoy muy triste y ay pobre
no es que me duele el cuerpo que no me
puedo levantar del sitio en donde estoy
es que no me apetece hablar con nadie es
que me quedaría encerrado en mi casa sin
salir durante días y días y salir es es
un milagro y para eso tengo que buscar
una serie de
herramientas que me permitan empezar el
día saliendo
eso como lo hago
yo no quiero salir lo primero que hago
por las mañanas antes de ducharme
siquiera es me he visto y me voy a
desayunar al bar de la esquina y así ya
he perdido el miedo a salir ya ha salido
de casa ya eso me lo quito de encima
entonces he cogido esa costumbre y salgo
de casa muchas veces vuelvo a casa me
ducho y si tengo que trabajar o tengo
hacer cosas en casa me quedo en casa
pero ya ha salido y otras veces no otras
veces lo que hago es sigo en la calle y
usa hago la compra hago no sé qué pero
todo de seguido vale ese es mi caso pero
hay muchos millones de casos
tenemos que tener en cuenta que la
psiquiatría general opina que no existen
unas enfermedades y buscan buscan por
medio de la neuroimagen por medio de
diferentes aparatos el diagnóstico en
salud mental pero aún así no lo han
encontrado cuando alguien se rompe una
pierna tuve esa y tuvieron a rota y te
dice no tengo que escayolar y tú no
pones ninguna
ningún problema pero cuando tú dices tú
tienes esquizofrenia y dices a ver dónde
te tienes que tomar estas pastillas dice
saber demostrar que tengo esquizofrenia
y por qué y para qué me tengo que tomar
esas pastillas a esto en salud mental no
existe a ti te viene un señor de blanco
y te dice no eres bipolar tienes que
tomar litio
por lo tanto toma y le dices para qué
y no te saben responder la mayoría de
las veces es más ni siquiera tienen
tiempo porque son unos señores que están
endiosados que dicen no porque yo te lo
digo y te tienes que tomar el litio
entonces hay un gran problema que es la
adhesión al tratamiento de las personas
con diagnóstico en salud mental que es
que no se lo creen entonces hay un
noventa y tantos por ciento de no
adhesión al tratamiento en salud mental
porque porque no confían ni en su médico
en el tratamiento
vale por lo tanto falta un
un detalle que yo no sé si vosotros en
este momento sería sólo una palabra la
adhesión yo yo no creo en la adhesión es
como tienes que tomártelo porque yo te
lo digo vale en cambio cuando tú tienes
una
un apego el apego es una confianza total
del bebé hacia la madre de alguien hacia
algo de no entonces la psiquiatría busca
la adherencia pero no busca el apego
y tenemos qué
hacer que la psiquiatría se personalice
se humaniza
y lleguemos a que los pacientes podamos
sentir un apego hacia ese hacia esa
situación que tenemos que vivir y así a
veces hay hacia esa
[Música]
qué evaluación que nos hace el
psiquiatra y creernos la y confiar en el
psiquiatra
cosa que hoy en día está claro que no
existe a menos que tengas muy claro el
síntoma de
de tu enfermedad y seas muy consciente
de tu enfermedad hay un libro para
acabar quiero recomendar a todo el mundo
si tiene familiares o tiene o tiene
amigos o hay un gran libro escrito por
uno
[Música]
un psicólogo clínico que se llama xavier
amador uno de los redactores siempre lo
digo porque es muy importante uno de los
redactores del dsm 5 que es el libro
donde se describen todas las
enfermedades mentales que existen pero
que no se pueden diagnosticar con
ninguna prueba vale todas esas
enfermedades que desde la hiperactividad
la esquizofrenia todos los tipos de
esquizoide es total pues hay el escritor
del de mes y 51 de los escritores xavier
amador escribió un libro porque siendo
él un gran psicólogo clínico en eeuu no
conseguía
tener una relación de normalidad con su
hermano que era esquizofrénico así que
dijo yo me paso el día con personas con
esquizofrenia dándoles consejos pero yo
no consigo ser amigo de mi hermano no
entonces él buscó la forma de ser amigo
de su hermano
e intentó por todos los medios ser amigo
de su hermano y se llama el libro tiene
un nombre muy bonito a mí me parece es
no estoy enfermo no necesito ayuda
porque esa es la primera palabra de un
de un diagnosticado en salud mental para
mí yo soy tan normal como los demás yo
no soy raros he sido siempre así vale
porque ahora soy un enfermo
vale entonces os lo recomiendo porque
vale da muchas luchas
aclara muchas dudas que podamos tener y
sobre todo me parece que tiene una línea
para poder relacionarse con una persona
con cualquier tipo de diagnóstico en
salud mental que va a servir para que
podamos relacionarnos con nuestros
amigos familiares pacientes
un diagnóstico en salud mental que se es
y aportación
[Aplausos]